so
yes sir hear ye
hear you a little bit around that where
the ninja's
at how's my level sounding y'all how my
love was sounding i see a lot of people
in here already
good to see you on a friday red stream
talk to me phil eagle what's up
patcha lord pop g what's going on six
layers scrub nerves my man will vote gag
is what's going on
oh wow thank you master clowns
said i'm a super chat thank you thank
you brother means a lot charles hawk
this is great wow
dizzy's grandpa thank you brother good
to see you
thank you for showing some love and
coming by the stream gonna have some
indie games going on
philly says the levels is good hollow ah
hollow is good no i see you can sign t
what's going on
let's stop what's up man good to see
y'all friday i didn't think it'd be a
lot of people
we got k oh the clown showing tremendous
love thanks for being you tweet our
super chat
much appreciate it man we're gonna
celebrate some games we got some people
pull up have some fun rudolfo
ramos dia oh greetings from mexico
what's going on may go let's go
that's what i'm talking about you gotta
be hyped mexico with the house you know
what i said
so that's what's up man love love of god
what's going on y'all
y'all ready for some uh indie love see
this id at xbox you know i'm saying tell
me what titles y'all want to see
a couple ones i got my eye on you know
stalker a couple other stuff but um yeah
we're gonna get the lords in here man
kings will pull up addicts will pull up
solve sadly is that work we'll have some
guests in the bills
in the building too believes uh sign
decks
uh maybe will be definitely and my boy
midway monster
should pull up mr master clown i don't
even know what to do with you right now
you showing so much love right now
in a pregame stream uh but humble we are
truly humble thank you
thank you again you are amazing no you
are amazing for being here
oh the gunk okay okay yeah hollow i want
hades
oh geez baby jesus he won a cent yeah
scent looks good i said looks good
oh wait oh hold on is that launching
gaming in the building i didn't even see
my bad my bad way hick i see you brother
you appreciate you on the editing
brother you always do your thing
back for dead what i'm saying i love
podcast destiny clan representing
you know what i'm saying oh man master
clowns thank you again
20 super chat gold you want to see a
sports game
so look man we just gonna chill hang out
all right philly says he don't care he
just want to laugh
yeah we gotta have some fun you know we
got some fun rain g4
the rain is in the building what's going
on what's going on
that uh yourself now live what's up yeah
cat
now lives is making it rain in here it's
the club throwing it up right now he's
bawling right now i can't control him
that's much appreciated yeah man so we
got so funny you know king go talk his
talk when he pull up
i might have to mute soon because you
know how king do with his copyright
strike and his theme musics
so you know how we do but i just want to
check out hang out with y'all for a
little bit
um there we go sign next you're going to
be coming in here real soon
you know what am i looking forward to
yeah i'm looking forward to stalker
like hollow said hades i would love it i
know it's a long shot
and to be honest i just want to know
what's going to come in um exclusive on
game pass i want to know if they got any
game pass deals
i love my indies oh man master clowns
out here making everybody look bad
he's op he can't be stopped he's open
he's definitely overpowered right now
absolutely
sick slam what's going on so yo i'm
gonna cut mike for a second like i said
king will be pulling up and
we already got enough copyright strikes
as it is so i see y'all
in a few minutes while everybody pull up
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
free city wow that's crazy first of all
master clowns man thank you brother
you're on fire right now 29
shot thanks for being you yo thanks for
being you y'all up in here on a friday
for some industry this is this is crazy
much love oh gee
it's baby jesus welcome to the oh i like
today looking for world domination
yes yes cat daddy what's going on he
said thanks for having the stream at 60
frames yes
everybody's pulling up we're just
waiting for midway to pull up then we'll
get this
going we will be using our xbox series x
so it'll be 120 frames
this is this is xbox friday so
that's 120 frames for those that are
capable and able
to control dudes this will be 30
stop that we're not doing four hours no
it's not
iop
all right let's see uh
um
[Music]
right now and we are live
we're going to get this stream and get
off the speakers
oh that's nice and we're live so we're
gonna get over to the stream
that we're supposed to be doing you know
what i'm saying so let's get twitch
popping
i will not be watching through twitch
because that means i will have to make a
twitch account
whoa you don't need to touch the camera
no i'm not doing that well
gonna see stuff like 20 minutes late
for a couple of seconds that's right
watching through the channel why should
do the chat that's right
i'm the man of the people all right let
me know first of all
oh you know who it is you guys are
ridiculous
it's too early for this i just woke up
just woke up it's
new actually look man i worked last
night it ain't my phone
in game pass we got pathetica
[Music]
have you ever played prey all right
there we go
let me know how how it is in relation to
our voices if it's too loud or
let me know how you like it i turned
them up a little bit
do you like us be sure to uh bring the
uh the boxes over
don't go in there with no boxes now
because it's what it is i want to full
screen it and the boxes are gonna
you know you should be able to full
screen and still bring it though i've
done it before
i'm gonna let you do that on your run
if you want a visualization of like
people would rather see us than that
little bit of gameplay anyway it's up to
you i don't care
midway now you're making kings you know
he goes
whoa am i who i say i am you are who you
say you also
[Laughter]
i got you bro i got you yo cat let me
know how the levels decided
yo me and uh i think cat daddy are
playing the new maps for uh
that stuff is fun mad fun man yo the
medics say you feeling yourself now that
you got a beard
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how are you guys yeah we're on the
twitch
twitch gaming
xbox showcase right here on twitch
now i am one of your co-hosts today
story mode bay and i have the honor of
being joined by the incredible
trisha hershberger trisha how are you
being joined by the incredible
story of bay hello
how are you doing today right i'm doing
good i'm
really excited i mean brianna and i
today are going to walk you through
so many excitements
right because the walking dead kick in
yeah joining us throughout the day
this is not what i'm starting with
historically
you said the developer guests we'll uh
down for a conversation with some of our
favorite streamers and creators
including awesome folks like kate stark
and stallion83
all right 12. age and technique
so many fun folks we'll also have
special interviews with
chris charlotte from ideas they're
putting ninjas
we'll have victoria tran from interstate
[Music]
interactive will get into their highly
anticipated games
[Music]
not the same
i worked last night too attic i haven't
got my two-year-old watching with you
thanks to you and king david for the pc
health by the way
which is awesome cat cities will meet
yes that is william
i am so excited about this now before we
do get started
with our show i do want to read it
i'm the only southern broadcaster in the
university we want to know what you guys
think i mean i already see the chat
moving and shaking as it is
i am super excited about this so without
further ado
uh i want to remind everyone throughout
today's id
at xbox at twitch gaming indeed
but that's not all we have so make sure
you stay tuned throughout the show and
share your reactions in the twitch chat
so everyone let's go ahead and get into
it
first up we're dropping some new
gameplay trailers
let's take a look let's get these gig
plate trailers let's go
this job xbox should be streaming
through us
oh this is my joint just the dinobot
joint the battle royale joint
and why they went wake up
there we go
exo mecca i believe yeah are we going in
the water
he said hey put that in your chest oh
the whips let's go
everybody want to have this little uh
grappling hook
my own thing and this they got the
silver surfer boards in this too
i see them doing so sorry is he on the
plane bro
this is i've been telling people
this is exclusive too how does the dino
show
i am in on this
like so mm-hmm
you really like saying that word don't
you oh
oh my god oh dad what's up brother
oh look they had the little uh
[Music]
like the little spider one what's up
with this this
test touching thing that you're doing
you
they're stealing nipples
[Laughter]
yeah this is a different type of indie
i'm with you this is different
that looks good oh they got grub lock
let's go
they got the all got the same tech look
they got the same suit look at that man
you got your guys our hardcore captain
for someone ain't
quite much of this they got one texture
it doesn't have
it's not called destiny
i have a feeling we're gonna get a lot
of um release dates in this
this is it turn it off
i did they were max well i know what i'm
watching i cannot wait to play this by
giving you a special assignment
success and you'll be given a chance at
earning yourself yeah i got them i got
twitch on max
they're loud on my hand okay it's loud
for y'all
no i mean i'm not watching but it's
whatever okay
oh look at that push windows g you might
have your
twitch like in general down
i loved i love stuff like this okay this
lets you know really what your pc
and what your xbox is capable of
look at all the blood splatter oh
oh that's cool look at all the little
people falling
i love stuff like this jay bar you need
to stop exo becca's
greater than halo infinite yeah it's
greater than anything on that
playstation too
i mean they they have no more i know
that it's coming
for you over there and i got my max i
got my joint up
hey jay barry aj because
aj barney when the playstation have in
the show no
it works fine on my uh push control g
and see if maybe in the past years must
be lower twitch
this game right here because they will
keep that setting regardless
on playstation 2 because ain't got no
textures on the face
volume is low i know y'all try working
on it i'm working on it
yeah but push control g i like this i
did
raindrop noodle head exactly why is it
every time i send you over that you
bring me more
i don't need four of them it was loud
when it started and i got all i was
doing
you've heard of cuphead coming in 2021
onion head
your man raindrop noodle head
savage
because you guys are good yeah because
they were loud when they started but now
when
we're good because we're through a
different program yeah
jay barry's like kicking into the earth
what's this omno
it's an onion neck tommy
oh we were close
welcome to the world of onion nick tommy
the only onion game that will make you
cry
oh this is this this is this yo look at
your legs
[Laughter]
this is life is strange the generation
is this
is this was this a playstation exclusive
last week
yeah this is clearly an indie show y'all
hey i'm just i'm just pointing out there
iops got a tear to make any of the lords
play any of these games
you're pointing out there addicts
volunteering
and king loves playing these games i'm
playing this game off the vert
[Laughter]
welcome to the realm brother thank you
bro
my man welcome to oh
i know you're gonna be playing with us
now christopher
said king you like all these cartoons
yeah you like it too because you got a
series
s i
welcome to the xbox world
you're gonna get dear ankles too that
was deer ankles
[Music]
indie game show no way how dare them
have ended
ever how did them give us games
[Music]
[Laughter]
i like looking at demos it's just a
trainer
that escalated pretty quickly
this is something i play this is you
i'm trying to find out the purpose i
don't know
but he keeps phasing this train keeping
i'm sure i can find some kind of
substance to make it easier though
this this is miss the real list
remember the iron lord box guy has a
tear on patreon
[Laughter]
there
[Music]
all right void train i see what you're
doing there uh behave will be
the last one that we just saw i was
getting like outer wilds
what's going on again from that
uh brianna were there any of those
trailers that particularly jumped out at
you
yeah i mean i
i'm very excited
when i get my
[Music]
you know when somebody asked me if i'm
gonna be on the show but you know i
shouldn't have to be like
yo yo remember them on the show i do
have a cold
i do have a coach
i did my job
let's just blame each other
what game did you see from that last
trailer
are you excited about it
there's a reason i've been a fraud in
destiny for the last week and a half
okay
that some people were comparing to
titanfall i don't know my first thought
when i saw those mechs i saw kind of
this
tell me once in the center of their
chest and i was like
400
type of game you think you could see
yourself jumping
i mean and it looks like it's actually
i apologize if the community
i like the mech tank that looked like a
spider crab
yeah super spidey crab tank look nice um
is that because there's a spider tank i
mean destiny
no i just like to have it um
leg man i mean
i mean it's a parent right who's not a
leg man
you want something with no legs
defend
[Music]
like i said that was just a snippet
[Music]
this is a huge hello
why is mob being purchased and it's not
gay pass because these girls ain't loyal
okay developing okay chris brown
that's right oh it's my biggest aerial
day it's ariel night
let's go he get his shine throw it
off every night yo
we debuted we debuted that's what i'm
talking about
that's my brother man [ __ ] doing
this thing
they gave a little they gave a little
two minutes no no minute two
oh princess farmer remember we have a
tale
for the uh iron lord i think the play
this attic is gonna play that's the tier
adding don't play it
is it up already gonna play this no
matter what
you ain't gotta pay attention to play
this this type of game he likes to play
anyway
we gotta find something that he would
hate nice one too
i need you to stop it all right
enjoy your show salute brother but king
is more welcome christopher heart
relaxes the indie show relax
especially if it comes to the game over
here because
don't playstation got a show nope
someone in the chat said i want
starfield playstation
8 and almost a month oh what's this
oh yeah that's that big game that's
i'm in that's me that's me
oh look kind of cool
oh he wait he weaving and knocking
people out that's my game
justin
shout out to the people who came here
this is an interesting crazy game out
here 400 right
strong man what's this look at this
right okay post office
back the big con
man i was hoping to see what was the
game that
playstation came out what is that i
don't know
that's all that's the song
[Laughter]
yeah it is
i think these are technically like the
smaller smaller indies that don't have
like giants oh that's good gryffindor i
heard about this one
i heard about that one i play that i've
heard about that i heard that's very
good ripley is very good
a lot of good positive things about it
i believe it's about 18 bucks check it
out great story about trying to be the
mob they their mom want you to get rid
of bodies if you don't want to get rid
of the bodies
that's right should have bought a couple
indie games to give away oh
that's what i might do man i might buy a
couple of these clowns
what's this dungeons and dragons
something the whole thing is dark
alliance is
thanks for having me look like you other
girls gotta pay for it now forever
yeah sure so basically we're a program
at microsoft that enables independent
developers to uh
i personally love indie games and i
think we've seen indie games
the back
[Music]
for a reason
and i don't
we're able to work with developers
um
[Laughter]
just a variety i mean we just saw on
that trailer and all three
[Music]
[Music]
shotgun farmers which is a game that uh
launched on xbox
office and watch shows excited
and dominated
[Applause]
you gotta remember king i worked with
always learning absolutely that's
actually who keeps emailing that
development company
and then do the personality stuff after
the show
aaa company i feel that whole thing like
this i mean
we've seen like such a great it wouldn't
be so bad like democratization
with the rise of vengeance
um it really is now enabled um the focus
you know games is still
incredibly amount of heart i just don't
like his mic man
developers by the technology as much as
they were
we were 10 15 years
yeah it is super cool
you know what you know we might talk a
lot about programming
we will definitely we might talk a lot
about the ideas
but like when an indie game like this
goes into game
absolutely
is
billboards
um
they go start taking advantage of the
power of it but they don't have to
get a phd to figure out how to use it
and so um
that is kind of always our goal to make
it as easy as possible
on taking advantage of the hardware not
like fighting against the hardware and
just being excited
this is this is not the way that context
in particular
this is not the way 370 people in the
chat man hit that like button
so that you
oh
oh
[Music]
i guess that would be my message
microsoft and everything like that
that's what it is oh yeah they love
these transitions they love these
transitions i'm like yo just stick with
the screens
stick with the scene let's go in
lightning although i see you on twitch
how all of this works it has been uh
almost
who listen to two streamers talk after
just listening to um
xbox section
oh yeah
going on here
um
yo yo
oh he said they having technical
difficulties
trailer thank god it's working now
i remember this one i think this is on
switch
this one it's on twitch yeah hit switch
all right here we go a game game
i was so happy with the game you got us
a minecraft oh this isn't
the same game in the same world
because all those stories
[Laughter]
this looks cool ugh sharon it looks like
something i will never play though
uh i guess i played with the game game
pass you gonna play
there's a lot of games in game plays
that i haven't played yet my son my
players this book is by your side
wait a second what's
we should have a tear inside of um iop
where king plays
all gay past games wait a second wait a
second i'm down for that
so
all right well
oh
there's some truth to these myths and so
it's a little spooky and you get your
fashion you get to cook
and sell and make friends around
you know so like while you're trying to
explain
the world to your uh
[Music]
what can you tell us
because it seems that you did a lot of
research into it so you must
like and very specifically eastern
canada i'll be like come here bunny i
just want to hook you
wait uh
[Music]
yeah it's like legend of the river
almost
10 years millennials 13 years ago since
it came out and i was like
no this has to be like we need to kind
of like see if it's feasible here so
like the the story is like the second i
met
living in quebec and
like my family has history fishing
as a kid i i helped run a little fishing
shop selling fish by the lakeside
and and it was kind of like you know
there's this connection
like this is actually really chill we
wanted to make a game that was very
relaxing
and this is the perfect kind of thing
he'd give it a higher score yeah
it was the perfect environment
from there started researching east
coast because
so it kind of
bit of mystery around the moment around
the town
all these big televisions tell us a
little bit about the game looks like
this is sure
which is basically there's a lord that
exists in the world itself
uh
[Music]
then coming back and cooking whatever
you've caught right
and then you sell it to lesser
likelihood
[Music]
and also in your
influence kicked in yet no i know i
don't see
this game already yo johnny could be
stopping
can y'all turn this off and just give us
another iop podcast stop it and it
influenced the art style for this game i
mean they're virtually kinda
and stuff trying to figure out like what
game do we want to know
and also i wanted the technical
difficulties
is
all the colors are much softer yeah it's
it's all intentionally like
catered so i'm gonna i'm gonna give this
anything even trolling
spooky difficult to just like the
animations like finish work
and then
a lot of people in chat mention that
exactly that exactly
i think you're on the right
lss
and all the side quests and stuff or if
you just want to follow the uh
yeah absolutely now what are you most
excited as the developers what are you
most excited for players to experience
when playing this technical
because we get really weird with their
designs and oh god i really love
black guys friendships interviews
difficulties so one of those things that
initially you're going to have
like where you're like okay and it's
going to be so bad
oh yeah it's massive the scope is these
people deserved
the first section
like we've been making this game for
over over two to three years
and um
so much
yo i tell my daughter
she walks back down here with a beer
like these weird fish it's taking like
from people's
thoughts
imagination kind of brings up things in
the scene
so and that's just
for a little bit but how did you do it
is
there's always something new and like
different i know it's only 12 a.m
so you don't have to 100 to complete
it
as someone who likes to replay comfort
games like this
and i think i would classify this as a
bit of a comfort game i'm very very
happy you know that there is that
yo did you say we need me to buy twitch
or xbox for this
how can people follow you uh for updates
bay
so we have the [ __ ] bay twitter account
and instagram account nobody's facebook
page
it's all at mungo bay and we also
see this at bunny hook games
because i got and also there is our
publisher that is also going to
be giving a bunch of updates which is at
coaching
like code
toasty okay that's right so that's where
we can find it
real question i don't know why we blame
xbox for this
benchmark for the length of these
interviews listing that as soon as i get
off of here
thank you so much
as soon as we got that little nugget of
lore where people
who die in the ocean people who die at
sea
their spirits and thoughts or whatnot
kind of come to be in the fish i was
like oh man this
this went from peaceful fishing sim
where i want to like
yeah no i completely agree i love how
he kind of called it a comfort game
because it almost is
a comfort game with you know um not the
death part
maybe i don't know how comforting that
is but it looks so
adorable and again the art style for me
is what really drew i mean everyone was
positive
everybody liked the game at first
sell everything in a vending machine
meeting different people
i've been sitting so long i'm
uncomfortable be indie devs who kind of
created this world i'm sure it's just so
exciting to
invite people into the world and see
what they do just like hands off we made
them
try to get a playstation our best please
go for it it's really cool
right yeah i'm excited i'm excited for
them
all right folks you thought this was a
good break but don't go anywhere we have
more exclusive trailers coming up i see
everyone
took a break from trailers
interviews with the devs from this whole
they probably did the three-minute thing
to figure out what's going on i feel
like i feel like something's up
like behind the door it's this right
here i need the symbol
they need a cab are you ready where do
we start this is a good commercial
yo what is this screen be back in three
minutes this ain't no sick huh
[Laughter]
see y'all see see anybody that stopped
grinding another video game you know
if you just hook that tablet up put iop
up on it
turn the bottom you know turn turn the
volume up and you know have your
headphones on and keep it going
mute the stream
i was on many strikes before we are yeah
but we ain't never got to strike
i doubt for this but
that's how much he cares about this
certain like event right
let's go all right we back sorry y'all
we had to do it
coming up soon blind gamer steve will
sit down with the team behind
supplies and later on we'll be talking
about it
from among us i know everyone in the
chat is
waiting for that interview about the new
map i'll be dropping in the game on
march
31st but first we have more
exciting game trailer reveals for you
from drifting
disaster gorgeous rally racing
two minutes probably enough of an indie
show
all right this is xbox showing indy now
waiting for the big show minus
chattering ding ding ding time
scrub nurse xbox is the founder
xbox nickname is can't get right and
let's not cap for this show right now
i'll be there baby paul
patrol i don't think anybody here is
camping for this yeah yes
75 possible at this rate cyberpunk will
be fixed and next-gen patch before
yo okay
that was good okay that was funny oh oh
rally we're getting dirt indie
low poly res little polly rash daytona
so this is 35 on the playstation and
free on xbox
let's do it but you know what there is
no gas station sushi
at least they showing something other
than the dog and the cat and the sushi
and the rats and
stuff like that we better shut up when
everybody dabs out and talk for 45
minutes
is it just me though or is this like the
indie graphics of choice
yes oh i mean i guess this is what they
got popping
right now
oh what's this
pocket they look like that game in the
attic like
they're ahead of us so they are out of
the stream
oh look why are they throwing cards
oh
[Laughter]
got some fortnite
they got fire chickens i'm gonna play
this
[Laughter]
like hey it's optimized
face punch dude punch you in the face
let's go oh oh you caught this guy like
going why is everybody in the drawers
what's going on out here
get him get him it's like pub g and ark
had it
remember this i remember this i remember
this
okay
[Laughter]
yeah this is big
i used to play it on pc i haven't played
it forever
they spent a lot of time on them
he had his out there this house a rocket
legend
rocket launcher you come out tommy i'm
sick and tired of you stealing all the
money drinks
this is my munchies with myself
yo ghoshy with the follower i can't
believe they show breath of the mild
time and this is how i chose to spend
the effort
what is this oh this is my joint this is
my joint
this is it right this this is the ninja
joint oh the electric ninja
this is the this is it i've been waiting
for this
i am not lying i'm not capping yeah this
is it this is
this is it right here this is it watch
this
tell me how tell me how sage uh tweeted
us
it said xbox is doing an amazing job
right now showing playstation fans the
game they'll actually be getting
instead of bethesda games
this is about to be it this is that
joint i'm waiting for this it's supposed
to be i think it's at the
end of the month or something like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're mad at y'all a lot of hating on
these indie titles shaking my head
no there's no hating on them i was
hating on the format of the show
don't worry about me and the enemy title
relaxing
[Music]
what is he doing in his house
so why are you in his house why are you
in the neighbor's house check them out
the window put them in there
is that what you do to the little kids
that they're right there i'll keep
somebody running in my house and they my
stature
all those missing signs is going up just
like that
i'm on the roof just like that i'll get
all of you
come back in the sky from his basement
that night
you have a feeling that that's the
that's the facial animations that he
does
that's right believes in your ideas and
series
and while you normally would he's going
he's going to check on his spider man
when you break into mr peterson's house
you'll be going against an a.i
why is it not called breaking and
entering
[Laughter]
why the neighbor got to be the problem
why not why didn't they
go
[Music]
if
[Laughter]
[Music]
should be a bunch of missing kids for
this
foreign
[Music]
and i was kind of trying to do that
from every little corner i remember
inside
the fact that they're making it and he's
even smarter than the first
i'm very nervous well that was one of
the coolest things about them
but the entire community's runs that mr
peterson is learning from
is frankly quite terrifying to me
although how to drain the water
we'll all have stories y'all be having a
flow y'all just
yo whoever's behind the production on
this right here
now i was going to say
is coming out with another game they're
the same developers
and even the style of the game it looks
very
80s and retro and almost futuristic in a
way
yeah that first trailer we saw uh was
for a game called art of rally
which got my phrase give it about
another third
a little bit a little bit of a uh we
hate to be wrong
yeah um a lot of people one bad mother
says it is four
the lords cannot do foreign
[Music]
for everybody to check out i know chat
is all about time stamp
up next on the show we have a streamer
blind gamer
yeah go to the ones you want to see here
new cooking inspired games
soup pot in soup you'll be able to make
food with a
wide range of local leaves for
is
[Music]
and by the time i logged in it was sold
out
[Music]
[Music]
there's nothing else that a call can be
doing right now so it's fine
that's exact chef that you said welcome
to the adam chestnut all right
said no i'd rather watch his cookbook
welcome to the anarchist cookbook
this is not even stuff that they show on
the nintendo switch show
the dolphins and traded the number three
pick to the diners for the twelve oh
okay
when you get pristine bread crumbs oh
awesome
what is
here we go here we go
it's really weird this is twitch this is
all twitch
microsoft they never do nothing like
this ever
why is this associated with microsoft
this is what happens when microsoft got
to do charity work to build people
[Music]
we just listen to the voices of our
ancestors in the background boogie man
i found super chat one eternity later
[Laughter]
you wanted to do the iconic cooking
methods like using our fingers too
how do you get there you get to learn
how to make
sushi and soup yeah i'm not looking at
another i mean
you're telling me
by
oh
is
uh and people really liked it so one of
the things that
is
is
is
uh
get someone from bethesda marketing
for my first time
[Laughter]
we've made
because of course i'm an accessibility
advocate and consultant so
accessibility is fun and what i do
so what are the other accessibility uh
features that you're gonna actually have
[Laughter]
how does
uh
they're they're trying to get
everybody to enjoy you know yes we must
remember if we were just asking
yeah i don't want them to go after this
demographic
oh my god let this demographic
go away you know
just to you know be honest about it
though could play it also xbox has been
doing this for a while
you can't
[Music]
drop plus you gotta keep in mind people
came here for stalker they came here for
12 minutes
like all the people that came here for a
specific
game like they're not having this like
this is the equivalent of buying a juice
and somebody's pouring half out into
yeah they should have said exactly they
should have had a schedule
saying okay at this time then this
developer is going to come out
yeah so we got a five dollars
every time you twitch lego flashes i get
the urge to buy something on amazon
[Music]
a minute
[Music]
uh
it's just making sure everyone holds on
to their stimulus checks so they have
some left for later this year
wow
is essential if you wanted to make like
gourmet food
and
the design of it also reflects that you
know over the fight been overwhelming
like what were you holding on to paul
supermarkets is it too early to start
drinking no it is not not
even drinking those things so you don't
necessarily feel that in the game
because you could buy whatever you want
yeah
and uh
there's a lot of people kind of in the
chat that are going to be wondering like
where like when can we be able to get
our hands on soup on xbox
currently we we are aiming for august
20 31st yeah and yeah
oh my god i'm so tired that is they
don't show they literally show you how
to do the recipes
uh all right so thank you so much
for joining us where can we be able to
find more information about
[Music]
uh
he said i can't believe i'm watching
soup boil no oh my god
because i'm out of here
for no three thousand dollars yo dale
lazaro follow
super chat the sliding cup is four hours
too but at least there's decapitate
it's fine you might have to talk later
i don't know why
no
but first let's take a quick break be
right back we're taking breaks again
wow we're talking about the stream we
don't want that straight
for the three minutes
we have more gameplay trailers to reveal
from the battle of normandy to the
skrama media
you said games must be next we got 30
minutes
it's it's about to be up
beam and turf this is it this is the
game this is your banger
look i didn't say it's my banker i said
the dude about to do the
i
actually i would play this platformer
right
i like watching green treason
i'm sure this is using all the power of
the series x
this little girl looking for king
baby
oh what is this oh
baby this looks like something from
dreamcast daniel said kyle did you see
that stasis yeah
[Music]
there you go
let's play this let's go freebie of
squads
come on we in we're in i'm so in i'm
already out
look at this battle for moscow
let's get it i'd rather play vr planes
trains
automobiles tanks let's go
let's get it leaving games this looks
thank you for saving my show let's go
seize them see pillage let's go
come on women and children
let's go how'd you kids
thank you for waking me up let's go
them seize them look at the game oh good
song
let's go we're heating up now that's
what i'm talking about
chivalry too
speeding with me too yo hit me up y'all
want to
shout out to wunder and dutch big small
mixer podcast they had this uh devil
yeah cause he was an unreal engine with
the two i like that oh what the [ __ ]
let's go look at the enemies oh
look at that look at the road to my name
and this is the
[Music]
into the background yeah oh that was
done
billy they killed him oh you see the
ball [ __ ] you want chase
let's go yes we're back you killed my
kids
we will get them when they start talking
again because you know it's a matter of
time
from the speakers of ultimate frisbee
comes the latest
in a world
[Laughter]
cross country
they going all the way live with this
son i don't care
this is how i wanted it to be excellent
[Music]
sage microsoft must have rehired
[Music]
that you were like oh we got a two
dollars
there was a place i think it was called
definitely caught my eye
it's kind of like
i'm excited about this also what i'm
equally as excited about
is our very next interview coming up
well this is how you draw streamer
taj is going to connect
the world from the developers
in an effort to beat back the calamity
is
[Music]
i like the eyeballs though the teeth
look crazy
that's like some uh grudge stuff right
there this
this this looks like something on game
pass kingdom play
of course i like the man i like to
change it to different animals
you look hollow inside
nobody saves the world what's up
y'all too far ahead guys there he is
let's start a 2020 stamp this is coming
soon
oh data test wow
grand smith and ian campbell from
drinkbox games
it's fantastic the uh the music's a box
the game looks fantastic
i mean let's talk about it there's so
many things to get into we don't want to
bring them in
let's write down i'm talking about
what's what do you guys want to start
i think we've integrated him before he
looks very familiar
yeah like i feel like we've run into a
lot of conventions
i don't know i think i think so yeah i
think i think we did
nobody looks very familiar but it wasn't
this game
before you interview these people you
should at the very least look at their
games extensively
like to know what to ask it feels like
some of these people just winging it
they didn't look at anything they just
winged it but i wonder if the technical
difficulties did play some factory sorry
i was just saying
and when you try so hard to go after a
certain demographic
on purpose you notice that you smell it
additional forms
you can't be climbing up the mountaintop
doing this in a quick nutshell
you can't do that you got to get there
first then do this
so if i so the forums it sounds like oh
yeah we got to get back
to being able to kind of puzzle
something
[Music]
um
and as you get further into the game you
can mix and match the ability because i
mean the animation and all this stuff
this is good you know like this is like
a polished game that's about the shadows
like a ranger or
a horse that's you know like biting
things in places like
whatever the possibilities are
you know this this really looks like
it's going to probably
i think that's the thing that intrigued
me most it sounds like
yeah i do actually call simon because
you co-signed a lot of questions
complicated
um like to start with when you want i
mean i'm gonna keep it a buck
but i mean i'm co-signing any games that
i can get inside game pass do you have
something over there i can play like
that no you don't
so so you're looking at games that you
see your perspective on playing games is
broken
different from mine you're looking at
what you have to pay for so you're like
okay i could save my money
i could save my money yet me it's just
about time
i'm already invested i'm already in i
think the club is open
buffet you've never been to a buffet
you're still going to a restaurant
picking up a menu
so then you so you have some flexibility
on it because it's a whole different
mentality
that means you really travel mad at us
like microsoft don't have two more shows
i'm not worried about those two shows
i'm worried about the one that just
possible
trevor is the former right now could be
better
that's what we said no one has a problem
with indies because when the indies was
popping three bangers in a row
uh
[Music]
with my food
at microsoft in trouble works like like
guacamole
talk about like this is what's right
this is not microsoft microsoft gave me
a bag and just didn't download
i don't care if it's on game pass and
he's getting more
like triple
or they don't look like a god of war
[Music]
um
rpg
it's all about presentation it's about
pacing so that's it nobody got a problem
with any games we see how excited when
the games are coming
when they show them correct unlike uh
yeah uh but scattered throughout the
world not giving me the grab bag
trickling out raising that don't give me
these phrases
give me a brown uh jelly breeze don't
give me
brown jelly beans over and over
you know i came so close recording this
for like
youtube video purposes that
is
is the fact that this is four hours long
yeah because if we knew it was four
hours long
because if you have a four-hour showing
you're expecting a lot of talking
because it's
four hours like an hour hour and a half
showing with indie games
so we expected so a lot of gameplay
different challenges uh so you'll have
to kind of mix and match
not only because you want to try and
push down the form tree by doing quests
different forms
but because some of the dungeons you
just take over
he gonna bring us home we gonna bring us
home
but there are some builds that feel
pretty broken so we can't just let you
do that dang it
[Music]
had this been
[Music]
dungeons you know what sage almost more
like
the bosses if that makes sense because
like yep
it's d for no star because like
like ryan was saying some dungeons like
they all have their different themes and
some of them are pushing like really
hard in certain directions like
i just came in this dungeon and there's
like poison everywhere and there's
projectiles lying at me everywhere like
how's it like okay what forms and what
abilities can i use to like overcome
this
and that's kind of man lucas
you're going on here
[Music]
they try to get the
that the bag need to be secured before
you start spitting
[Music]
butchered that we're going to move past
that though i actually played children
yeah you don't want to play well you
don't want something to be too
frustrating
for them i just like the visuals of
looking at the
i can actually see cognito playing that
for a whole game
they definitely haven't they have you
mentioned
[Music]
um
to launch it looks like it's something
that's going to actually uh be
out there
it's going to have your time i mean it
looks great i'm not lying i'm getting
attached to your drink
um twitter i'm going to put
how long
that you would like to show off today
about nobody saves the world
i like that i think we covered most of
it we covered most of it he's like let's
continue i'm out of here
awesome they're not sure fantastic
they're posting before
before we fully wrap up where can we
where can we find nobody saves the world
where can we
see online and what sort of things
should we be following right here
uh you can definitely follow us on
twitter drinkbox studios
jack is flipping out all the time we
just did another day was known
where it's
that's normally a playstation dev yeah
and
it's on xbox it's not a playstation
thank you all so much all right
thanks to graham and ian for joining me
thank you to everybody it's awesome
it's game pass too it's on your list
because
nobody saves
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
aaron says no one can save the stream
we're trying man we try
but they only got us till two
because i feel like there's so many
games where you play
and it's almost like it's done but no i
don't care
i do want everyone to know monday i
don't know what day i'm so excited
it takes that at home i'll probably
still
[Music]
someone
oh yeah um but i mean we've got
so much to get into today so let's go
ahead and keep this
party let's keep it rolling yeah we've
had so many great game announcements
already we have a number of titles
never before revealed okay we're done
now before seeing
okay yeah yeah let's go let's take a
look at those
no no
[Music]
this looks like a turn based type of
game magnificent and generous nature
features
it's harsh besides ourselves
here we go in the world
after she does that she got that one
thought oh that one time
that one guy
[Music]
adding all day watercolors
oh now i need to be okay this is so well
i would buy this sometimes
this is something all this is game pass
man stop it already this is funny they
have not completed
this all 2013. all 2013. oh my god
raider blade 2000
people remember it's indy now
oh it's game pass kick is right oh this
is good that's the first time they say
get
fast i mean this is the first time in a
while
they said yeah but it's all game pass
all of this is game pass bangers
and it's optimized yeah
what is this
[Music]
what is this the real winner tonight all
right god
look look at least something 60 frames
jeez all right let's go transparencies
all right we're here now hello
post apocalyptic they rolling down on
you oh he got the older ninja with the
flying with the wings ain't nobody got
nothing to say now
where the hell
zelda was real
yo this is your game boxing or macarena
no no textures this is macaroons without
the animation
this is what happened this is what
happens when they don't got the
animation team
yeah i take all silver every day
give me all silver with the movement
and dinobots i'm good you know what
are you saying this is my topic
listen man this is all keg he can have
you know what it says
this is what i'm talking about
classic turn-based tactical rpg all
black oh they show money back just
oh okay so which one what you call
that from game of thrones when i like
the one that got killed at the red
wedding that's how you look like
what's that one that got killed at the
red wedding yeah what's the star
that got killed at the red wedding y'all
that's him yeah that's rob it's the rob
stark game
let's go
they already got my money that's cool
no body shaming
let's go look man i don't get my my
brothers in
in that in that realm so you know i
gotta support you you know what i said
we don't get to see us this is it right
here
oh they got it i'm done this will be
this is wilmy right here y'all
and it's optimized discord that's part
of the discord deal y'all
know more similar are you kidding me
got that toro man get to get that
toronto
i will get to super chats when they
start talking oh my god oh
here we go what was the name of the one
that
[Laughter]
this looks like something
this looks like something kid would
break his face yo this is
it right here tetris ninja wow
you still okay i'm not playing it dude
look at the teachers
they take the away plus beak oh
[Music]
also very excited for something oh
that's all you missed lawn mowing
simulator you need that
i got to support that intense they got
my people in i'm good
going simulator than that that goes um
yeah that is incredible and again like
you said there's so many fans
at home watching you guys go play go
download
what's that game called what's the
what's the wii in the game a couple of
questions about
long moments
[Music]
what was that game i was i was captain
what's the word that i liked
is that cool whiplash
um
[Laughter]
as well
yeah he lost it
um
a new map the airship speaking of
airships is dropping into the game
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
trailer for the new map now
oh it's among us
it's a giant i love this game oh see we
still in the past
[Music]
look around everything make sure no
cameras see you yeah yeah yeah you're
right
act like you're doing things if anything
this is teaching you how to be a
criminal
yes make sure that people see you in
places
so that you can have a great alibi yes
when this comes to xbox we're gonna have
to play this a lot like a lot
this is lion to see game teaches you how
to manipulate
hello victoria how are you today
i am great thank you you really touched
me with with that company it's like how
so much how like
modest they was when they were so so
they were crying
it just shows that like sometimes these
ideals
yes i think everyone's just think you're
going to make a game that a lot of
people are going to like
and then before you know the biggest
streamers on the internet are playing
like that would be overwhelming can you
tell us about the airship
absolutely yeah so the airship is
actually
dropping on um in like five days oh my
goodness five days ago
so it's very soon
maybe they'll say something about it we
have some free hats coming with it as
well as some cosmetics
this is an xbox showcase there's gonna
be ladders and moving platforms it's
gonna
i've told you all this is a lot of fun
for everyone to play with and
we are really excited for it to finally
be out
uh can you tell us for those of us they
really like to let's go ahead and get
that server going so we can all jump
into the xbox
you could tell like you could tell they
know about they have a fully connected
vent system for that they're all
connected all the vents are connected
oh i'm so excited i'm so excited to see
how everyone
uh gets around to murdering each other
i cannot wait to in in the best ways
and by the way this is my first name and
last name
[Music]
now i did recently learned that the
airship is going to be the
89 match available does that mean that
there will be a reason
you see new tasks in the background
playing
yeah so there's going to be all new
tasks available
there will be one new death animation if
you buy the additional cosmetic pack
that comes with it
um as you can see it's based on henry
stixman which is
another game that we made in the past so
there it is uh it's right-hand man's
kill animation so we're hoping people
have a lot of fun
oh man are you allowed
it's only for playstation you saw i mean
you saw
but we will have some new free hats such
as
unicorn hat like a little some angry
eyebrows
you know you can only do that on one
network
poop it's um chocolate ice cream and
nothing else
definitely doesn't look like anything
else
thank you for specifying the world
honestly okay so i know it doesn't i
don't know why
i got a playstation upstairs
it's just like something it's just so
simple and there's really nothing
how much of their gameplay do you watch
when thinking like oh man we need to
switch it up
oh it it really depends right now so we
do try to keep up and
there's a lot thankfully we're very
grateful to have a lot of people who
play among us so
that's really cool but we do you know
try to keep up and see who's playing and
kind of their strategies and see
the kinds of cool things they come up
with but within ourselves actually like
we
with our game design and with our own
like qa and our own play testing
uh it's really a mix of like our own um
sensibilities
and years of making games
super chat yeah id at cringe like show
me tunic already
immediately stuff like that that it's
kind of like through playing it you're
like
oh this could be tweeting and not just
necessarily like tweet to make the game
better just to give people options of
what you want the difficulties
my settings are going to be very
different than if i'm playing with a
bunch of these
[Music]
we've had classrooms of people playing
we've had
that's so cool i am kind of curious
because i have been an imposter on my
mind
um are you able to maybe kill
someone
yes
all i know is we better not go through
all this so they don't ask them about
flat are you like i swear to god
yes platform you think it's not coming
to xbox
no i just want to hear yeah
you need to stop it all right though
like how is it not on xbox with the id
xbox
[Music]
incredibly busy within the last year get
to the point already five hours of chat
time tell the twitch host to stop making
us play interview simulator
this is not the way oh my god i haven't
showed that game yet
showing some love keep it behind it
thank you
and we wouldn't trade it for the world
or anything
but wow we are tired and anxious
[Music]
that's as sweet
[Music]
[Music]
straight up just broke into my house
turned on the stove made themselves a
whole meal
and i didn't notice because this show
put me to sleep
[Laughter]
uh and then she shaves if it wasn't a
little podcast this would be a watcher
for thank you
that's all i wanted thank you you know
what he said we here for y'all not this
simulator
i'm excited about it coming together we
got the best the rome is the best
[Music]
i don't
all day long but if anyone has any
questions
or wants to know where to find you do
you have
a gig is good
get one month for one dollar join
playstation
ain't nobody in there
uh yeah i can't say that dude i've been
on p.s
thank you for having me playstation now
is a good start it's just not
to save themselves
but sometimes the next game
right it's like i kind of you know
that's the thing
this probation is tough i'll never bad
gay yeah you are serious probation i
need apology too
so don't go anywhere dare you tea bag
guys and trials how dare you
oh
oh we got to mute y'all they could
strike
a very interesting time to go to the
playstation commercial
you know what's
is to be able to just oh don't you say
butt first 12
minutes but wait but wait there's more
but first for a half hour like you said
we'll chat with you
did you get the chlorine to drain the
pool so in death story
i wish i was there to imagine if i had a
screen shot and tweeted talk about crazy
every time i beat somebody
imagine if you were teabagging someone
it would be
clear and then tweet the content
creators
there we go here we go
[Laughter]
he gets a pass assistant they say
i'm about to see this team whoever's
doing has got great animation
so now you're gonna be hunting her huh
yeah we hunting her
we got tentacles after after the 12
minutes though i'm getting off bro that
bird strapped
nobody want no problems oh
no he pulled out boss let's go
how about this one go through the door
[Music]
he did good behind the crow yeah he said
he said
also uh david i apologize
hashtag it wasn't like yeah you gotta
get it right
it's kind of a dark kind of mystery
[Music]
in death store it's amazing so it's set
in a world where there's presentations
i've got a bit of lag sorry
it's set in a world where nothing dies
naturally anymore
so this group of crows who work in this
office that we saw in the trailer and
they are in charge of reaping the soul
of the dead and maintaining some kind of
order in this world
one storyline that's a single player so
you can play from start to finish
the entire experience has some light rpg
elements in it so like
that's why i need you to fly yeah
speed and basic stats like that and you
can also find new weapons along the way
and out in the world you'll have loads
of different scenes to discover as well
so it's almost like a hundred percent
again
a lot i'm going to use the sequence
they didn't do the research
little touches
you can actually pick up an abandoned
umbrella in this office where all the
crows work
and you'll get an achievement
that one right there hey addict may well
be yeah i haven't even investigated
myself so i can't even comment on that
souls
yeah i think this one is certainly a
very intense action game and it's
definitely going to challenge
how they go from one thing we wanted to
do this created something
yeah i like it you go inside the door
really hot you don't just have to keep
trying overnight
uh
take different approaches and overcome
challenges in their own way yo when
ratchet and clan come out you can see
something
you tell us about the combat system how
many different weapons
ain't got no games i probably won't say
the exact number of weapons but there's
a there's a few two there you go
got a five dollar super chat from the
state subject fast pace
is
that gives you what you need to overcome
anything like that is more like an
accessory yeah it looks incredible yeah
so what about replayability how much
replayability
will this game have my son likes that i
think
the first thing i would recommend doing
when
when they're starting and when you've
finished the game then the first thing i
would
that safe because suggest actually let
you carry on afterwards
and yeah
loads of different things like saying
before it's a really good one
like they've got different color
controls because we've got
literally
this is true it looks really
so there's quite there's a few there's a
handful of uh good busted characters in
the game
as you progress through you kind of uh
the core bosses have their own
storylines they've developed i mean you
kind of
interact with them a few times while
you're on your journey
and so by the time you get to them you
may be know that backstory you're going
through
their area of the world which is kind of
like they've
left their mark on the world yeah we
really want to show
how these bosses have adapted to the
strange situations
that will be on twitter in the next five
minutes
how they've affected the world around
themselves
you know we're bored when you're singing
birdies where can uh
players get their hands on this game
when is this coming out
pretty far along with it whereas we're
almost content complete we're just
polishing
the penguins shiny um
hear about
um
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
a couple of concept artists and a 3d
modeler
where everyone has a lot of creative
input i don't want you
world so the actual people's color and
overgrown like interesting the way
people does come in this is the office
where the reapers were
just kind of trying to hook up to homies
depressing bureaucratic environment
that's what i'm talking about yeah
[Music]
so basically the way that they the crows
do their job of reconciliation
they have these doors which can lead
them to any place so
that's how it works
via shortcuts
for all the people out here that work
the ship's watching first
you know shout out to workshop right
here all of the developers but
especially these smaller
studios my goodness i need to feel bad
he said 12 o'clock he's at 2 o'clock
you take it out there's a little bit of
heat on the outside
made a really great game love the dark
mood gg and
uh tons of love and chat for now you've
had microwaves since
you really tell me you scared the
probably glowing in the videos
from all my years you know going over to
iraq i'm still going
out of the year so definitely you never
have the radio on in the kitchen and
then you turn the microwave on and the
radio starts
getting all staticky um
yes thank god
updates to games we're all dying to play
i see you guys in the chat movie
let's take a look at some more new
gameplay
trailers here we go you know what they
think they think
that this brings in that demographic
that they're trying to hunt
after in studios
oh this is um what we got
what's this
we're gonna have to play this one
yeah we ain't baby we already know how
we do why we gotta do this
you know what this reminds me of what
was that the game
that came out with four players how
about me
like do you know you have to be the
monster
oh you talk about evolve that whack yup
but this is just
this this looks like evolve nah we can
i want to see i got to give this guy
april 28th was it yeah
look at that game pass what i told you
all this dope what's up with the big guy
oh i like this
they could take shots to the chest
uh
with a big hat he's talking about
piccolo
that's like a turban that's not a hat
that's just this is why i don't like you
referring to dragon ball you don't know
which time
this is definitely stupid
[Laughter]
coming to xbox later this year why are
we conserving the wildlife what's going
on
what they had to do with the world
old school yeah that's us this one this
is for the people about to collect
social security yes
yeah if you don't know about this one
who yes yo hit it hush and get up
that's the blaster you tell them
[Music]
we got a real
yo don't be mad at me because i don't
know anime like that
it doesn't say game pass
[Music]
that's what we're here for
i think they already showed this but i
missed it so it's new for
oh my god it's awesome yet completely
renewed
[Music]
[Applause]
i'd rather see boots
look at the details look at the details
[Laughter]
is
all right niceness
bolt action so they call in the game
drip tool
give me that saw let's go
let's go live and look at that get your
gun on
i was just rested on the table i just
sent it to you at it
there you go that's you rest it you just
lay down look down sight and just
let her rip as they walk through that's
some g's
yes
that i've been bamboozled food
hoodwinked before
i'm implying that i don't believe you
dude
people so that's all stuff right now
you're not showing me
anything this is nothing show me the
game
i want to see gameplay not none of this
none of these
still formats of the rotating of the
camera and the control environment
in the background with the purpose
none of this take duct tape oozies i
don't care about
none of this stuff right here this means
nothing to me
king the miserable gamer
you're realistic lord miserable
[Music]
they have been showing these guns way
too long yeah they really have
us here at armchair developer studios
will tell you how to make your game no
no no no cognito you're doing it wrong
you have to do a deeper voice
in a world where they want to fool
that that's how christmas oh
look at this slot box look at the slot
box
best stop box of the business that's
that's the facial expression
[Laughter]
in his mouth
i'm still saying that so chris righteous
looks like
they got a slide please subscribe to our
official social channels
or ask any questions
[Music]
wow
my god
[Laughter]
the updated costumes looks super
realistic
uh look at some of those weapons
like imagine it comes back
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely
important to give developers
to push these games out and allow them
to do them properly
i know there's so much hype behind so
many different games but
developers are people too
machine
well thank god we made it 12 minutes for
the last two hours
y'all so far in the future there we go
louis antonio oh returning oh oh
this is 12 minutes right yeah
look at it every day they get beat up
you can do this guy comes every night
out of respect the animation team for
the footsies and the cuddle game you
gotta respect that
william the first yes you know when it's
william to fall in it
no he don't put his name on much imagine
well today i have the pleasure to bring
in
luis the director of 12 minutes i like
the midnight i'm here as tommy
as you guys know it's crazy how the
community blows up this show
this game when it doesn't expectation
it's in the bushes shame on your
expectations
shout out to the lord hashtag game
passes because it
[Music]
long time ago i remember seeing it when
i was younger everybody said that was
the same trailer
mine and it was just reminding me of
yeah
nothing sir nothing this
[Laughter]
on the run throughout the chat king
reminded me of the neighbor indie game
and um he attacks you you pass out and
then you go back to the start of the
evening
and that's really knowledgeable that
you're doing the promotion for your
fellow neighbors remixing the
again what happens inside the apartment
it's all in real life you're back at it
again and
i just the game if there's no release
date this is now kind of
up to you to decide what's this out
already
it was released
imagine if we got stuck in a 12 minute
loop watching this
where is the game going to be it feels
like this this feels like groundhog day
every time i pick my head up and they
drain in the pool
how to overcome this [ __ ] by the way
guys that
um one dollar so the game where the
final stage final finals
29.
very soon
it's very interactive so you can
actually buy that one by the years
they'll wind up better and and
the voice overs and the narrators
more detail yes so the the whole
experience probably because the game
never really tells you what you should
be doing
it's a bit about how you interpret
what's happening and so it's a very
personal
um intimate environment where it's huge
yes i mean two other characters and um
and yeah so the voice acting is there to
really help they must be going but
you gotta connect with this character
to be able to follow the story and see
where it leads
that's a very very important factor is
connecting with the characters and
and and finding some kind of
relatability to feel the emotion that
your main character feels or main
characters i should say
um and those mothers talk about really
ability
everything happens in the apartment so
the controller aspect of this game has
to be very important
can we look forward to now all
playstations come through
have 10 minutes of game play on some
games
you never quite know what's going to
happen you have objects in the apartment
like
on the trailer you can see picked up a
knife there could be a mug there's the
plates
so anything you can pick up you can
combine with other characters or with
yourself
and then there's things you can like
open the door close the door and
it might seem that it's not that kind of
interaction but each one
the characters everything i appreciate
your service branches
system uh you know the body is the body
pick up a knife it comes in an apartment
you might have a consequence now
you have a um i'm guessing this her
husband
that comes home to his wife
is
12 o'clock i think yesterday was
when i saw this was on twitch and not on
youtube
[Music]
say the cop comes in and he starts
attacking you right you could try to
fight or not fight but each
each each option that you choose will
branch out
so you always check the frankie he said
the crow would save the stream
learns everything
i'm looking
no you don't got conquerors because they
haven't released all six so
they're only oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but
i
beat them all with all my um subclasses
from play testing we
i thought the game would last about two
hours
what i would call a satisfactory ending
please don't throw no parties for this
black show
it's trash it's
i
my goal with this is
i respect
oh
it you know yeah i'm talking about video
games uh trailers i'm talking about
games that i'm going to actually
do i can't i can't on twitch
for promoting their platforms that's
what they're supposed to do wow
yeah if people want to watch
i don't have time to watch somebody else
get past the board
i don't care for that that's not my
thing if i want to do it
and if this isn't your apartment i teach
my son but he still watches these
weirdos play these games
[Laughter]
but most of the people on twitch aren't
like that though
it's all about gameplay at the end of
the day
you know we might not like this but i
gotta respect twitch for like
putting their they they could have
people easily
this is of not giving us too big of a
loop so we can just
i just think when you say that showcase
so much about games it should just be
reading about those games
and if you want to do this
just keep showing games as long as
you're showing me gameplay and i'm not
just looking at a screen with people
talking
mm-hmm but no because you might see
something they could like kind of
explain certain pride
you know so that's what i that's the
thing that
is
it's not like they're like like uh
they're audio cues to what's going on in
the show they're literally just
talking and they can literally just have
hours gameplay this is the first time
that when they told you don't expect
anything what is it that's right
they really meant that rebirth did come
out and
this is going to directly affect the
views they have for the next things from
the
movie industry like from the cinema this
is going to be directly effective
right we get to see the game and we're
like oh this is cool
the other but it seems like he's had his
12 minutes
a lot of those tools that you got from
all those other developers and brought
it into making your own
holidays
i wouldn't i think it's cinematic but i
would call it
don't say enough for playstation so why
would you i think it's like
these three games has this background
the only thing that saved this show was
the lowest coins and goals i'm like
what if we bring some aspects of it you
know i'm not going to let nobody smack
your face
experience you might as well put your
hands back in your pocket
i don't think you're being disrespectful
no i mean this is
it could have been brought to you a
whole lot better but like what twitch
wanted to do
was highlight their experiences
this is this is all this is all this is
this is all twitch
and i can understand that but there
could be a great little group there
could be a middle ground
yeah and the thing is some of the
interviews
nobody
as well like when you hit your first
loop on the second loop you know this
guy is coming
where did you go you know this is the
only time this is the only this is the
first show um
is
[Music]
is
i don't know about none of that stuff
[Music]
[Music]
but suddenly the body movement and the
voice acting they
elevate the experience because you're
you're kind of projecting what they're
saying
i got a nice dude too because you don't
see exactly what the face is like
and it really helps it's an inside joke
okay so let me give you the inside joke
on that right so all rap stars from new
york
new york and new york is the hardest
city was broken
because everybody in new york was like
i'm gonna take up the whole show
so that's how we feel my friends
that's the website there's a development
blog that i've been writing for like
five years now you can
officially move on with my life i'm
eating
announced when we had a release date and
i'm always posting stuff
three or three times 12 minutes
or i don't think they are i think they i
didn't
[Music]
thank you for your time thank
we try to rock out as long as we could
but uh as you know oh back the drain in
the pool yeah
you know the chad what did he hear right
away before we head out but i would let
us do our sign outs and good stuff but a
king
how did you feel brother before he
rolled up out of me okay so wet my beak
too
river was definitely it it was it
definitely hit
um i i like uh at death's door um what
was that other one with the guacamelee
yeah i would look at it that you know
devolver uh
digital is uh is a great development
house
i think they they they know what the
pulse is i think they know how to pick
uh the development games that they they
want to showcase
yeah and um and they all play
in a manner that's how can i explain it
like game plays first
and then it has a style to it so
devolver digital to me
is that that indie developer that is
really the backbone of what's going on
out there right now
for me yeah um the show y'all y'all know
if i'm gonna give it a pace and give a
pace in a negative 20.
um if if you if if you want to
ask me uh how i felt about uh
the the the length of the show as far as
the content of the show
i would give it a four the length of the
show was
what brought it down the content of the
show is the crux of the whole four
yeah um because they show regurgitated
content when they did show
stalker all they showed was nothing in
the background
and then sure he was going it all
started uh
yeah yeah it was absolutely they showed
nothing
you know they show games on pcs uh
probably 30 90s on development kits or
whatever
showing you the best of the best the
highest of the highest the 4k textures
with nothing in the background zooming
in
as close as possible like you ever gonna
do that inside the game when you do get
the game
you have to take an account ai you have
to take an account the world
you have to take an account you have to
take account all that other stuff
the game will never look like that on
launch i don't care what anybody say
you can take still pictures and zoom in
and do all that
i'm going to show you and the game will
be running at two frames per second
right now on that slot box
you saw the face they did things on
purpose to distract you from the world
stop falling for the banana in the tail
fight that was
if anything that was a banana in the top
something that everybody was looking for
um to me this this show was a dub like a
go
like i could have really stayed sleep
for this um
i kind of is you know you haven't made a
mistake
and realize your life could have been
different
it was that one turn in life where you
could have made this man
remember that book those books that we
used to read the ginger powder
hey you'd be like hold on i'm gonna go
to page 13 i'ma drink the juice
king drink poison i gave over
i should have i should have put the
drink in the sink
i'm gonna try to go i can't go back in
time i don't got to rewind
but you know it was some stuff there it
is yeah
what i like is most of that stuff is
going to be on game pass
if not all the stuff is going to be on
game pass at some point in time
no doubt it just sucks that it's a black
eye
and that black eye is going to be
associated with microsoft opposed to
being associated with twitch
nothing you know so because their name
is on it yeah i'm fair honestly
attic let's get the lord first for a
change your thoughts sir
alex first i'm eating he's eating
thank you awesome to hang with you guys
but
i have got to get out of here my phone
will not please women thank you for
pulling
appreciate you bro gaming behind the box
own my man will be hood always showing
love to
talk and stream with you so we got that
and uh is uh midway still in the
building he got quiet yeah i'm still
here no doubt you should
yo you are you okay
are you awake uh i think the voice
represents the
mood of what happened these past three
hours i mean it was uh
i mean obviously the the word of the day
is game pass
yeah all the stuff is going into game
pass and
there were there were some some uh
things that intrigued me in there
and then obviously some that weren't so
yeah
um yeah it was it was a great time
uh thanks for inviting me the first time
on the uh
on the uh iron lords podcast so he
sounded like
somebody you invited over and you had a
bad meal but you trying to be nice on
the way out
like we we we hosted it first time he
was like oh yeah thanks uh
i mean the fool sucked but that
[Music]
thanks the lord you know after the 200
episodes you know i thought i was gonna
get a little something next
it's always a fun time being with you
guys you know like if we're going to
suffer we're going to suffer together
we're going to be excited and it's still
a fun time you know forte
uh this is like the second or third time
you know interacting with you
xbox live or on a podcast so it's always
fun hearing
no doubt hearing your thoughts and
hearing from you uh
but yeah um midway
monster on twitter i'm also part of four
guys with quarters yeah
got some great interviews popping up
mm-hmm uh
because i also coach high school
football i uh
uh clowns was uh very nice to kind of
get like a little friday thing going
just uh
just to keep me in the in the crew you
know because obviously if i if that
didn't happen i would have had to take a
hiatus from the
coffee for the kids from the group so
but uh yeah friday nights we do a little
friday night chilling
and then uh yeah the main show is on
thursdays so
again you know we got some gaming to do
so
brother you know how we do it for real
yep king david you always entertain me
no matter good or bad thank you brother
you uh you you're a great personality in
the in the in the
in the in this you know the
said you had the time of your life yeah
right shout out to wilmie
penguins bruh yes penguins no crows
no doubt and of course you already know
much love brother
we gotta see more of you and of course
my man gaming forte with the muted mic
where can the five people find you what
you got to say on the rollout
yo yo first of all midway thank you i i
forgot i muted my mic
um that's that's that's the kind of
thought process i'm in right now about
this show
like lord it was it was just like a a
yeah a muted mic
basically um no i liked a lot of the
games
uh death's door actually looked really
really cool right
like that's it that's a that's a sup
boss like okay let's let's go
but um i actually like the the moon glow
game the fishing game oh you like the
fish again
i mean i like little stuff plus my kids
that's something that you know i kind of
when i look at these games i look at
stuff that you know my kids will sit
down and like watch me play or i can
watch them play
so even if it's something i'm not
interested you know and that's the thing
that kind of is weird about the show
you may not be interested in it but it's
something for everybody here
and i think that's the direction that
xbox has been trying to go in for a very
very long time they're trying to
diversify their portfolio yes and i
think that's a great thing
but listen if i ever have to watch
another stream on twitch
it'd be no i can't do that no more um
and i don't want to make it the fault of
the show it's just the the format that
they use
but overall i mean you know for what i
saw outside of just all the back and
forth talking from
developer to um streamer
what's good i just think they need to
tighten that up and make
it a little bit more palatable because
you know when
xbox tweets out that we're doing a game
showcase and they actually say that
don't expect anything you know over the
top and they actually
truly mean it this time they also got to
really take into account that
they're pulling in an audience of people
that normally don't watch the content
that they like to put out they got to
like
they got to kind of take that into into
their um
take that into effect when they come
into that because we are used to just
looking at
gameplay somebody consistently our
bodycat
there's a digital stop tapping for it
that was true whatever
listen listen the show was not trash the
format was trash
let's just be for real about that you
know and we're just and we're going to
show the the negative side always comes
out more than
you know the positive side because the
stuff that was negative
literally sucked the air out of the room
oh my god someone read that super chat
oh my god suggested sage
follow us if your house got foreclosed
during the stream it was that bad being
carried out on my favorite [ __ ] he's
stupid
no no man but uh no it was it was it was
a decent show it could have been better
but um i truly and i just enjoyed being
here with you guys made it past
thank you thank god listen listen i i've
been a part of iop
streams long four and a half hour
streams that were more entertaining than
that
but love brother lord addict on the way
out man you finish your food
yeah raisin bran was lit
so you need that too wait
but the true question is cereal first or
milk first
cereal cereal first if you put the milk
fresh you're awake that's disgusting
that's some weirdo stuff
look at the whole pre-milk oh you may
put the milk in a bowl first yeah no no
no
if you put if you put the milk in first
i think you need to get checked in
no free milk in the bowl
listen the response i got to that answer
from most people say
the reason they do milk first is because
you don't overfill your
milk your bowl with cereal because you
put just enough cereal
to the contents of how much milk is in
it maybe i don't want to determine how
much cereal before the milk goes yeah
yeah
yeah i don't i don't get it either
because it's like to me it's like
driving backwards yeah that's average
stay the hell away from those people
that
that person will kill you in your sleep
those people are those people are
slow-mo isn't it oh yeah another thing
too
um this was meant to be drunk throughout
the day
in that show
this [ __ ] they're supposed to be
throughout the whole day
almond milk french vanilla thank you
he's not getting paid for that so we
striking out from the record
the second you cut him a check he'll
tell you where he got it from and what
was inside that
cut him and check and he'll say that
we're gonna go right back to that stream
and you're gonna hear me talk over that
where you got man
i think it would have been way better
even with the the crazy ways they done
it
they would have just been do
play gamepl 12 minutes new game play on
stalker
well at least we we know something we
literally watched three and a half hours
and we don't know anything new a lot of
repeat
games that are gamepl together past day
one so i mean i i got some of it but
that could have been youtube
oh yeah right absolutely i got to watch
but you know one thing i want to give
this
a shout out to the realm
like almost we had over 400 people
watching that stuff watching that with
us like straight up
guys that you guys definitely show up no
matter what we do and we can we
always appreciate it shout out to dude
he said we've been watching
another bottle he said the real show
starts at 50 minutes will be 10 hours
long
the iowa podcast raiden blade two pounds
of chat we have all level up to
sainthood after this show absolutely
all i know is if you guys need hosts for
any kind of event you guys know who you
are
you already know what it is look back
like i said i had a couple who stand out
shout out to um excellent mac i've been
waiting for that
you know 12 minutes obviously i wish we
had new footage what'd you call it i was
stalking two we had i wish we hadn't
finished shout out to that inclusion
game i don't care what nobody say that
game with the weird name
i'm all about that game it's about three
games song of iron looked crazy
yeah and it was onion head on your head
that one
yeah yeah yeah they had a couple of
joints yeah and some of the
the bird what's the bird one the the
killer crew left the door
yeah that door like they had a couple of
joints pacing was just wet
that's your name for the game anyway
[Laughter]
a lot of good games just again just uh
presentation format
pacing just and again like king said a
little bit way too much focus on
personalities as opposed to the game
and too much repeat gameplay and you
know it feels like they didn't have
enough gameplay for certain spots and
they just wanted to talk their way
through
i feel like this is more on xbox than
twitch because
they gave it feels like they gave the
reigns to twitch and just switched
you know without the let's highlight our
streamers and i can't
front twitch for trying to highlight
their talent
yeah they should have been microsoft
like look i get what you guys are doing
can we trim some of this here somewhere
there but you know i can't hate on
twitch for doing twitch's job
like at the end of the day also i got to
say this i know we clown him but
from what we heard there was some type
of technical difficulties i don't know
if that threw the whole format off
but in the beginning remember in the
beginning the pace it was hard like
literally the first five minutes was
like the first
15 minutes so maybe no real gameplay for
a long time
and they kept trying you know one of the
biggest issues
too is it didn't feel like there was
asking good questions like
it felt like that's my point like it
didn't feel like they were asking
questions like gameplay mechanics or
anything like that like
some of them were some of them wasn't
like i'm gonna tell you right now i was
not listening
to nothing that they said not one word i
had it
not into my ear now all i was doing was
looking at
games i don't care what you are saying
because your question that you will have
for a developer will definitely not be
the same questions that i'm going to
have for a developer
i don't i don't i don't care about tommy
that compressor a button that's having a
conversation
with a developer i don't care what i'm
doing
it's just that's just not my thing show
me games you said games is going to be
here i came for the games
no not like we said it should have been
we've gotten games the problem is like
we say they should have just showed
the games how much green how much time
for that
no no they stretched it oh they milked
it they milked it yeah they did that
yeah we know they've been out of there
we'd have been out of there 34 45
minutes 45 minutes if they
show back-to-back games and then have
the developer
or whatever talking in the background we
don't see them
no personality how about this what about
this
how about they show the trailer of all
the games right
and said now now we sit down exactly and
then you bring them out
like yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
y'all can do this yeah then we could
leave
bob 18 for the steak
they should have done the facts they
should have cut it to time frames like
they watch all of them and then at the
end they're like look i know some of you
want more information on some of these
games
and then they put up a time frame this
is the time slots come back when you
want to watch the game
and then they had a dude on the couch
talk about this is your life and all of
that stuff they was doing
you know what i'm saying like that
that's where i was at they just got too
much with that part and they lost me
but anyway look long shot you know
appreciate i just know that
i developed a cold watching this
stream all right this stream literally
made me sick
that i'm stuffy
my throat i can feel like i got
something's coming you feel like you're
coming down with something
everybody enjoy la i'm gonna get three
hours of sleep see y'all in three i'll
be doing the last word
and oh yeah and tonight i got tonight
darth castle x
um forte what you're doing you doing 15
more podcasts today what you're doing
but you're going to be doing what
podcast you want today
oh oh yeah yeah crossfire tonight i knew
he was on fire
so you won't be doing nothing with me
today no doubt tomorrow
who said i'm not gonna be doing nothing
with you i got the whole day still i
don't gotta work okay okay check this
out this is how the day is gonna go it's
already three o'clock right now
okay i'm gonna go shoot out here and go
grab my wife then i'm gonna come back
here right
i got a podcast at nine o'clock so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to die my
biggest i ain't dying my beard
okay so that's going to happen right
before the show that only takes like
five minutes
take a good you know shower or whatever
yeah
and then i'm going for the evening yes
so i'm not going to be seeing i'm not
i'm not
so basically what you're saying is king
you are going to be available anyways
tonight
no every time i'm available you are
never available and then when i'm
available
all night long um i send you messages to
jump in the chat where you at though
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa one man hold up
hold up i got a whole bunch of
wait wait hold on next box live receipt
i got i'm looking
listen listen january 19th is the last
time i got a message
no no message no message no man i don't
message you
invite so you know your invites go away
with your notifications yeah yeah yeah
no i don't listen listen listen i have
seen i will give king crazy i have seen
empires when i wake up no no no i don't
ignore him
he said i just don't say nothing
i saw them all right let's let's let's
uh let's all right
all right you said you ain't gonna be on
tonight
okay i will see you tomorrow they've
gotten it straightened out
everybody will notice on sunday if forte
did not show up
and these will be had been waiting you
gotta do anything right you're chilling
little podcast tonight right you
chilling
the podcast that's right coach football
so all right
catch the kids and help coaching
football throwing the spiral lit
all right that's it that's all i got
i'm tired i gotta get three hours of
sleep see y'all
last word catch y'all later peace
[Music]
rubber dog we got you so what's wrong
squad red man tell the job thank you
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
oh